I didn't bring you here just to sip some
tea I wanted to spill some tea so I
thought of a game I like to call it sip
it and spill it and it's basically a
very sophisticated version of never have
I ever
so I'll start because there's something
I'm actually very interested in and I've
never seen a ghost and I want to see a
ghost and I'm very mad that I have it
have you ever been scared by the high
clear castle ghost
okay you're sipping I haven't been
scared by it but put it this way when
shirley maclaine was on the show she of
course is probably lived at their castle
she said he said she's been in this room
before as we sat there having dinner so
I think that's one step removed from
being in touch
oh my god she was there the day before
we were filming that wasn't you this is
why I love her she's slightly nutty we
have the same birthday I'm slightly
nutty so yeah I thought forces are all
weird but yes but we're fun right um all
right so anybody want to go now maybe
Elizabeth you want to go sip it and
spill it if you have a DJ alter ego at
this table a DJ alter ego what I'm
always that person at a party I get all
the tunes going and everything and my
Spotify playlist is called DJ Dockers
however that has recently been blown out
portion and apparently I'm spinning the
Dex and I be throw me it's not true okay
Michelle go ahead sip it and spill it if
you're related to Indiana Jones Harrison
Ford what my grandfather was an explorer
and he was the first white man to go
into Tibet and he wrote a book about it
and then he did a whole bunch of
exploring in his life and somebody on
Google made up that he was the
inspiration for Indiana Jones yeah
that's way cooler than the Harrison Ford
thing I thought but I was like okay okay
I still like yours all right
sipping spill it if you've ever ridden a
bicycle on a motorway I decided to shake
it up a little and instead of taking the
car to the dance rehearsal I would ride
my bike to the dance rehearsal and
everything was going well and I had my
helmet on it was going and I went up
this little slip road and
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
everybody's so excited about it this
really deserves to be seen on a big
screen because because it's so much more
sort of lush and vibrant and epic than
we had even on the TV show which in
itself is quite cinematic and I think
that's that's the major difference I
think fans who followed the show from
the beginning will be delighted that
it's a continuation of the story and
even for people who don't know the
characters in the series it's a it's a
standalone story and it was really the
support of the fans that drove it
they got us all back together because I
think if that appetite hadn't been there
from the fans and then we wouldn't be
sitting here now your lovely tea table
sip it and spill it if you've had the
greatest time ever well you do in
America I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this